professor Julian sirrah share the Nobel
Committee what discovery of the water
this year so this year the Nobel
assembly has awarded the 2015 Nobel
Prize to William C Campo and Satoshi
amaura for their discoveries concerning
a novel therapy against infections
caused by roundworm parasites that's
jointly and the other half is to to you
you for her discoveries concerning a
novel therapy against malaria I was at
the press conference and it was a bit
quiet it seems like people are not
expecting this Christ why is that well
probably as you know the Nobel assembly
and Nobel Committee we keep most of our
work very secret and so for me as chair
of the committee I'm always quite
pleased when people are surprised that
means we've done our work well and every
year we get between 300 and 400
individuals nominated and so in some
ways it's been very difficult to almost
guests who the laureate might be with
that many individuals nominated each
year so i think i'm pretty happy that it
was a surprise the world of often abell
stated that the prices should be awarded
to those who have confer the greatest
benefit of mankind so how does this
price fulfill this criterion well I
think these two discoveries are a really
good example of conferring the greatest
benefit to mankind because both of these
discoveries have led to therapies that
are against parasites so camp a little
more their discoveries have led to drugs
that are used now to treat round worm
infections and this is causing diseases
like elephant tss and river blindness
those two diseases are really
debilitating people have lifelong
suffering because of those diseases and
this drug therapy now can reduce the the
disease
you u2's discoveries have led to drugs
against the malaria parasite and that is
also saved the lives of millions of
individuals so within the idea of Nobel
I think we have examples here that have
conferred the greatest benefit to
mankind you know these therapies they
save lives they prevent disability and
they prevent the spread of infection and
they also improve the life well-being of
individuals and economic growth so I
think this is a great example well Nobel
would have been happy and why we're
surprised amor de mal why do I this way
this year well you every single year we
start with a new plate and the committee
and the assembly have been working very
hard going through the nominations and
we came to the conclusion that this was
the best you know constellation the best
prize this year and that's why we're
here to talk about these laureates what
are the key breakthroughs that make
these laureates worthy of Nobel Prize I
mean who did what did what so you have
to think of it as two parts so Oh Maura
was working in Japan and he was really
interested in identifying microbial and
it might microbe antibiotics so he went
to soil and he had a hypothesis that he
would be able to collect soil samples
and they would have bacteria that would
ward off infection and so he collected
soil samples and cultured them in his
laboratory and he looked for samples
that had unusual properties and that he
then selected from thousands of cultures
about 50 of these samples that he said
on and Campbell could take these samples
and give them two animals two mice they
took life alized broths from these
samples mix them in the food of mice and
they could find that they had
anti-parasitic effects they could kill
parasites in mice Campbell also took
these compounds and he tested them in
livestock in farm animals and cattle
poultry domestic animals dogs and he
could show that he
compounds could killed Ron Warren
parasites he also Campbell could show
that there was durability that one dose
of this compound was sufficient to kill
parasites for up to a year these
experiments these discoveries led to the
clinical development of a drug called
ivermectin and that was used later to be
able to treat people who had river
blindness you you too she was part of a
larger project the project had probably
little little progress she came on the
scene she took the challenge of turning
to traditional Chinese medicine and she
was surveying different plants for their
active compounds against malaria and she
identified one plant Artemisia I knew
that was effective against killing the
malaria parasite but initially her
results were mixed so she went back to
very ancient chinese literature 1,700
year old literature and she got clues on
how to refine and work with her
extraction procedures and from that she
was able to identify an extract that was
a hundred percent efficient in killing
the malaria parasite she then went on
and tested that in bunkies and later in
humans so was this considered a
breakthrough at a time when this
findings were presented sorta I think
that they know they were because they
were so efficacious so they were seen as
a breakthrough no um admittedly the work
of you you too was largely seen in China
and that really came to the Western
world some years later but it was clear
that both of these compounds ever mekt
in first with Campbell and artemisinin
with you you too we're seeing to be very
effective in killing parasites one was
killing wrong more parasites the other
one on the malaria parasite sis are a
lot of young people watching right now
and how we explained in an easy way to
the importance of this price to a grade
school
I take it down to the grade school level
you can imagine that if you are going to
go on an African safari you're going to
go to the tropical regions of the world
where these parasite infections are very
prevalent you would take along your
mosquito net you take it along your bug
sprays but you may still get bit by a
fly or a mosquito that might transfer
either the roundworm parasite or the
malaria parasite to you if that would
happen you would become very ill because
of these drugs we now have therapies
that kill these parasites very early in
their life cycle they not only kill
these parasites but they stop these
infections from spreading so it's one
way to kill the parasite another way to
stop it from infecting other people now
if it turned out attention to laureates
who are they okay so um Satoshi ohmura
is still active he's working in Japan
he's a microbiologist and he really had
a long history in working with soil
samples and bacteria and trying to
identify active compounds from bacteria
that could be efficacious he's still
active as a scientist today William
Campbell he's a parapsychologist he's
retired he's less active scientifically
but he had a long-standing career
working towards developing antibiotics
for the livestock industry and was
really instrumental in taking these
therapies towards the clinic with his
other collaborators you you too again I
believe she's retired but um she's in
Beijing China at the China traditional
medicine Academy and had worked for many
many years utilizing traditional Chinese
medicine and finally haslam vell
committed being able to reach any real
audience so urban has been successful in
contacting um dr. amaura this morning he
was delighted and he was very pleased to
be awarded the prize together with
William Campbell
thinks he's a very nice person he's
really excited about this this joint
award we have not been in contact with
William Campbell nor have we had contact
with to you you I just so much okay
thank you